this might get loud the European Space
Agency has created something
extraordinary a large European acoustic
facility or beef which is basically one
of the world's loudest boom boxes forget
the ear-splitting the agency says it can
create a sound so powerful it could kill
you for massive nitrogen gas powered air
horns blast sound into a 50-foot tall
sealed chamber reaching volumes up to
154 decibels that's about a hundred
times louder than a jet plane taking off
the Europeans use leaf to test weather
satellites can survive the intense sound
waves from a rocket NASA for its part
used to tone down the acoustic assault
of space shuttle liftoff by spraying
hundreds of thousands of gallons of
water over the launch pad now leaf may
be loud but European rocket scientists
do have some competition please all
paint step there's a whole subculture of
decibel drag racing in which people
compete to create the world's loudest
car stereo the volumes inside those cars
180 decimals making locket mantras in
comparison sound downright polite